And this was a tricky question.
I would pick this one.
This one over here is obviously not good because we
even misclassifying our existing data.
These are on the wrong side of the decision surface.
So let's take this one out.
But the one going vertical here does correctly classify most data points.
Except for this one over here.
And also comes very close to the red cross over here.
That's something we're going to explore later in this class.
But for the time being what you should notice is that what
you're machine learning algorithm does it takes in data and
it transforms it into a decision surface.
D.S.
That for all future cases
can enable you to make a determination of wether it's a red cross or
a blue circle, and that is very powerful.